la crise sanitaire at elle changé notre
regard sur les déchets on en parle avec
vous abderrhamane el aoufir bonjour moi
je vous êtes le directeur général de
dérisoire environnement on parle ici
maintenant des déchets métalliques c'est
votre métier donc nos vieilles voitures
nos vieux frigo on en produit 14
millions de tonnes par an en france
c'est beaucoup par 14 millions 14
millions c'est le la quantité produite
chaque année à peu près de déchets ce à
l'échelle de l'agglo de métal déchets
métalliques qui sont produites chaque
année en france c'est l'équivalent peu
près de 14 millions de des véhicules
deux voitures voilà maintenant on en
vend 2 millions ça fait cette année de
ventes cette année devant d'une voiture
il sauf que tous ses biens de
consommation en fin de vie vous voulez
recyclé mais ces déchets métalliques
aujourd'hui valent de l'or vous le savez
avec les prix des matières premières qui
flambent les matériaux c'est alors tout
bénef pour vous les matières premières
et d'un métier qui est très cyclique les
prix varient en fonction de l'offre et
de la demande aujourd'hui c'est
aujourd'hui c'est très haut parce que
avec la crise sanitaire il ya eu un
décalage entre l'offre et la demande les
usines sont arrêtés et puis dans la
crise pendant la crise et puis après la
demande est repartie et bien reparti et
il n'y avait pas suffisamment de
matières premières et donc voilà il ya
la demande étant supérieure à l'offre
les prix ont monté voilà on parle
beaucoup des justement des pénuries de
composants de matériaux le recyclage de
nos frigos des machines à laver ou de la
voiture c'est une réponse aussi quelque
part face à ses problèmes de pénurie de
matière
alors il ya deux façons de produire de
l'acier et à un produit de l'acier à
partir du minerai dont on comprend du
minerai de fer du cocan produit de
l'acier et à une deuxième procédé c'est
de produire à partir des ferrailles
recyclées
ce qu'on appelle la filière électrique
il va de soi que cette filière
électrique va se trouver je dirais
beaucoup plus favorisés parce que la
crise sanitaire a été un accélérateur de
tendance est donc la dimension
environnementale a pris beaucoup de
place est donc aujourd'hui les
sidérurgistes nos clients sidérurgistes
ils sont tous en train de réfléchir
comment produire de l'acier à partir de
la filière électrique et à partir de
ferrailles de recyclage
donc et c'est une bonne chose à la fois
pour la planète pour nous donc le
déchets métalliques et vu de plus en
plus comme une matière première
secondaire s'estimant c'est une matière
et studios de matières premières issues
du recyclage carla quels sont les
déchets métalliques les plus recherchés
aujourd'hui par vos clients les
industriels c'est quoi c'est le le
cuivre l'acier parce qu'on voit les
cours qui flambent alors on fait la
distinction entre ce qu'on appelle
ferraille pour schématiser c'est tout ce
qui prend à l'aimant et tout ce qui est
non ferreux comme le cuivre le plan
l'aluminium le bronze de l'étang
aujourd'hui je dirais que tout est
demandé 1 il ya pas de différence sauf
que les métaux non ferreux cents à des
prix beaucoup plus élevés que ce qu'est
la ferraille pour donner un ordre d'idée
aujourd'hui la ferraille on va être
entre 350 et 400 euros la tonne le
cuivre on est plutôt entre sa timide
7500 euros la tonne un décor donc c'est
les secteurs qui achètent c'est quoi ce
sont les constructeurs automobiles les
le bâtiment b les producteurs décident
alors nos clients ce sont les
sidérurgistes pour ce qui es ferraille
pour produire de l'acier et les
métallurgistes pour ce qui est des
métaux non ferreux les sidérurgistes
reproduise houde ce qu'on appelle les
produits plats à savoir la voiture la
bosselle le principal consommateur ou
par exemple les réfrigérateurs les
machines à laver ou les produits longs
les produits lancés pour la construction
sans des poutrelles des cornières ça
coûte combien de recycler un
réfrigérateur
alors aujourd'hui il ya le coût de
recyclage en soit c'est à peu près 1 300
euros la tonne ce qui fait à peu près 15
euros le réfrigérateur sachant qu'un
réfrigérateur il un point moyen de 50 kg
d'accord après il ya la redemander ou le
revendre et combien ça vous coûte 300
euros la tonne ça c'est le le le coût de
revient le prix de revient
d'accord donc ça c'est les
amortissements le personnel énergie le
fait de recycler la comme le frigo après
il ya quand vous le revendez ou le
revendre à combien alors ça c'est
différent
il ya différentes composantes dont les
réfrigérateurs il ya de la ferraille il
ya des métaux non ferreux en moyenne non
oui alors on peut dire aujourd'hui 400
450 mais le problème il faut savoir que
nous on achète un on n'a pas honte de
dire qu'on les prix augmentent c'est pas
comme si on avait un puits de pétrole
quand les prix augmentent on augmente
aussi nos prix d'achat il faut récupérer
des réfrigérateurs
plus cher nous vous les rend plus chères
on les vend plus cher mais on les achète
aussi plus cher est ce que la crise
sanitaire a changé un petit peu notre
regard sur justement sur les déchets
métalliques même au delà de ça du côté à
la fois des consommateurs des
industriels on s'est rendu compte que
tout ça était utile qui avait une
seconde vie c'était vertueux pour la
planète et en plus ce que c'était
rentable alors pour nous on fait on
continue de faire toujours le même
métier le recyclage des déchets
métalliques c'est au niveau de nos
clients qui sont rendus compte
aujourd'hui avec la déco banos
décarbonation de l'économie qu'il
fallait changer de méthode on peut plus
travailler à partir du minerai qu'il
fallait donner la priorité à aux
matières premières secondaires issues du
reçu aussi que l'âge est donc pour nous
c'est c'est une commande hier c'est une
bonne chose puisque on est assuré
d'avoir la demande sera toujours là donc
notre métier si vous voulez existera
toujours après ce qu'il faut ce canton
lance un produit fabriqué avec des
métaux très en amont il faut penser à
son recyclage des débuts c'est ça aussi
la clé nous c'est ce qu'on appelle l'éco
conception donc aujourd'hui on apprend
de plus en plus mal d'accord alors trop
lentement
aujourd'hui on peut réduire que
pratiquement n existe pas avec le
démarrage des des reps ça veut dire la
responsabilité élargie des producteurs
on espère qu'avec les producteurs ont
s'asseoir autour d'une table et de leur
dire voilà qu'il faut pas mélanger trop
de produits dans un dans une seule
machine parce que après il faut penser à
leur recyclage et pour ne pas polluer
rien que dans une voiture il ya des
dizaines et dizaines de sortes de
plastiques pour séparer ses plastiques
entre eux y ait des plastiques qui 100
recyclable à 100% il ya d'autres qui ne
le sont pas et c'est très difficile de
les séparer on n'a jamais on finit
l'action n'a jamais autant recyclé
aujourd'hui les déchets ces déchets ce
traitement des déchets qui explose ici
nous qu'on a fait une bonne nouvelle
pour la planète oui tout le monde a pris
conscience qu'il fallait recycler tout
le monde encore de plus en plus on va
aller chercher le dernier point de
déchets métalliques
on va les avants ont laissé par exemple
deux ou trois points qui partait en
centre d'enfouissement ou d'incinération
donc aujourd'hui les exigences sont très
strictes et on va chercher le dernier
point de mettre métalliques dont déchets
c'est une bonne chose pour la planète
bon voila merci ap rahmane el aoufir
directeur général de dérive bourg
environnement merci merci beaucoup
[Musique]